well good evening from London good to be
back in our Capital City Welcome to
Piers Morgan un sensitive there could be
no meaningful and Lasting peace in
Israel without a two-state solution that
is surely a fundamental fact it means
both sides of Mis intractable conflict
recognize another's right to exist it
means that Palestinians have the same
rights as Israelis enshrined in law it
daes the Flames of burning resentment
which rage across the Middle East and so
much of the Muslim world and in doing so
it would ultimately make Israel a safer
place place but prime minister Benjamin
netan has abandoned all pretense of a
two-state solution with increasingly
asendur rhetoric he's made it crystal
clear that he sees only one state from
The River To The
Sea I clarify that in any arrangement in
the foreseeable future with an accord or
without an accord the state of Israel
must have security control over the
entire territory west of the Jordan
River that's a necessary condition it
clashes with the principle of
sovereignty this weekend Netanyahu
doubled down again President Biden spoke
to him for the first time in a month
emerging optimistically from the phone
call to say a two-state solution is
still possible even with Netanyahu in
charge but then Netanyahu responded by
posting this I will not compromise on
full Israeli security control over all
the territory west of Jordan and this is
contrary to a Palestinian State and the
hardliners in his own party are backing
him to the hilt they say that even
discussing a Palestinian state is
rewarding violence and putting a price
on terror but that is the text but
rhetoric of an occupying power it's
precisely the dynamic that has
radicalized Palestinians against Israel
there is no moral defense of Hamas and
no justification for its barbaric attack
on October the 7th I've made that
repeatedly clear but there's also no
defense of calling Palestinians Human
animals for claiming there are no
innocent civilians in Gaza over for
saying the common goal of all Israelis
is to erase Gaza from the face of the
Earth all genuine comments made by
supporters of Netanyahu since the War
Began Leto looks increasingly like he's
clinging to power and pandering to the
hardliners in his cabinet to keep his
job former Israel Israeli Prime Minister
ehu Barak today told Netanyahu in the
name of God go warning that Israel will
sink in the Gaz of mud for years to come
if he continues to lead the country
protesters today storm the Israeli
Parliament to demand netanyahu's
government does more to secure the
return of their loved ones still held
captive by the very people he vowed to
eradicate yes Israel must defend itself
every country has that right and Duty
he's right about that but he must also
recognize that the war cannot go on
forever Hamas is both a proponent and a
product of Oppression without freedom
and rights more radicalization will
surely follow one of Israel's most
distinguished leaders once wrote that an
open-ended allout war in Gaza would be
Hollow and self-defeating the Hamas
leaders would come out from their holes
and declare Victory among the ruins he
said who was it that wrote those words
Benjamin
Netanyahu well joining me first to
discuss this is Israeli government
spokesman Mark reg Mark regev good to
see you uh and a belated happy New Year
we haven't spoken this year A lot has
happened since we last spoke I have a
simple question following Benjamin
netanyahu's rhetoric in the last few
days which is what gives Israel the
right to believe that it should exercise
this kind of control over Palestinians
rights to have their own
State the right of self-defense the
right of my country to live in security
the fact that we have to base peace on
realities and not some sort of pip tream
and the reality will always be for the
foreseeable future that Israel lives in
a tough neighborhood and any peace
understandings reached that don't take
that into account and aren't built
solidly on security and an infrastr
structure of security no such peace can
survive right but but is this open-ended
then is this forever is Israel's
position now a totally implacable there
will never be a two-state solution
because Benjamin netanyahu's words
certainly suggest
that so you've seen and you know that
over the last half decade we've seen
peace break out between Israel and a
series of Arab countries the UAE Bahrain
Morocco uh you've seen talk of a peace
agreement with Saudi Arabia which the
Saudis despite the current fighting have
still said is is on the table now we
believe as Israel moves and is accepted
more and more by the Arab world and this
is ultimately a very very positive
process that that will also affect
Palestinian opinion and the sort of
extremism that Kamas represents will be
destroyed in this war will be
discredited and that will give room for
moderates and we want to see the
Palestinians join the circle of Peace
but a peace that is based on reality not
on pipe trims how many Hamas terrorists
do you think you've
killed so there are a couple of hundred
that we killed on our side of the border
on that first terrible day of October
7th and in the the following days
immediately after that Massacre uh we
had to take them out we those people who
invaded our country and so forth and
since the operation in gas started we
think over 9,000 of kamasa military
Fighters their armed terrorists we've
we've taken out and and killed right so
less than a quarter of hamas's believed
force of 36,000 or so uh depending on
which numbers you believe but my point
being the amount of Devastation both in
terms of uh human life that's been taken
including civilian life of women and
children over 10,000 children is believe
may now have been killed if you
extrapolate this to where to the end of
Hamas which is what your mission
statement is to eradicate a mass these
numbers are going to get to catastrophic
levels and leave nothing left in Gaza
are
they I disagree first of all the numbers
are Hamas numbers and and have to be
taken with a grain of salt fromus would
have you believe that you know the
over with respect so so are your numbers
you don't know you've killed 9,000 Hamas
terrorists can I tell you when we've
made a mistake with numbers we we've
corrected ourselves you don't know
you've killed and a half thousand do you
you can't that is that is that that that
is the intelligence information that we
have we think that's an accurate number
it could be more it could be less but
that's I mean people are always asking
us for our numbers if we don't provide
them people say what are you hiding well
how how many you know okay just to push
you on that if you can be that precise
about the number of Hamas terrorists you
must also know how many civilians you've
killed so how many civilians do you
believe you've killed no but it's a
little more complicated if if a Hamas
fighter is wearing civilian clothes is
he civilian if he's a 17-year-old man
with an AK-47 a 17-year old boy I should
say with an AK-47 is he a child or is he
a combatant in other words Kamas plays
with the numbers they want you to
believe that they're all children
they're all women uh no Israel does not
Target innocent civilians Israel does
not Target gaza's civilian population we
target Hamas now have there been a a a
civilian caught up in the crossfire
between the Israel Defense Forces and
the Kamas of course they have there
hasn't been a war in history without
unfortunately people being caught up in
the crossfire without civilian
casualties but are we making in Israel
an effort to avoid that of course we are
for us every civilian death that's a
tragedy but for Hamas who deliberately
uses Gaza civilians as human Shields
it's not a tragedy it's their strategy
they deliberately embed themselves under
School under hospitals in civilian
neighborhoods even under let me let me
how does this war end it's only today
you dozens of family members of hostages
held by Hamas still well over a hundred
being held storming into a finance
committee meeting in the knesset
Jerusalem shouting you won't sit here
while they are dying there so nearly
half of those hostages have still not
been uh brought back you've only killed
by your own figures you've killed a
quarter of Hamas terrorist so three
quarters are still there your mission
statement is to eradicate Hamas um the
infrastructure of Northern Gaza has been
pretty much obliterated similar thing is
now happening in the South again I just
ask you what does what does Victory look
like how do you know when you've won
this war how does the world
know so in in the northern part of the
Gaza STP we've already destroyed hamas's
ability to organize in uh to operate in
large scale military formations we've
destroyed their battalion I we've
destroyed their brigades you still have
the Odd Squad or two that can cause
problems but as an organized military
force Kamas does not exist in the
northern Kaur strip in the coming weeks
we will achieve the same uh victory in
the center and the South and then we'll
move into a campaign of counterterrorism
of counterinsurgency because ultimately
Kamas will be defeated as a military
machine and Gaza will be free of Hamas
as a ruling power and I've said this
before we simply cannot live next to
this Terror Enclave just as you wouldn't
want to live next to some sort of Isis
caliphate on your border we refuse to
live next to this Hamas Terror State on
ours ehu Barak who ran Israel says for
around three months now prime minister
Benjamin has prevented discussion of the
day after in the inner cabinet this is
unconscionable the IDF cannot optimize
the probability of winning when there is
no defined political goal the absence of
a realistic goal will end up mid and the
Gaza Quagmire fighting simultaneously in
Lebanon and in the West Bank eroding the
American backing endangering the Abraham
Accords and the peace agreements with
Egypt and with Jordan this kind of
conduct drags Israel security into the
abyss and he says this when prime
minister netanyahu's approval ratings
are languishing in the early 30s which
is similar to President Biden's in
America and is believed to be the lowest
number of any incumbent president who's
ever had to run for reelection so these
are bad numbers you know have former
Prime min mins of the country demanding
the Netanyahu resign um I suppose the
obvious question is why hasn't he I mean
would it not be easier for everybody if
he stepped aside now and let somebody
new come in and try to guide this to a
conclusion which can actually
work you know it's interesting because
I'm familiar with the polls that you
site and others but the truth is as
following if you ask Israelis do you
support the war aims is articulated by
the Israeli government which is to have
hamas's military machine destroyed to
bring all the hostages home and and to
destroy this this Kamas ruled Enclave on
our South to destroy their political
rule you get overwhelming support from
left to right to center 80 90% of
Israelis I heard today the leaders of
the Israeli labor party they they
proposed no confidence in the government
over economic issues but they don't
propose no confidence on the the waging
of the war and the war aims on on the
contrary Israeli Society is United that
Hamas must be destroyed as a political
and military force and you can
understand why because when Kamas
crossed the border on October 7th and
started killing us they didn't ask us if
we supported netan or we opposed him if
we're left or right if we're religious
or secular if we supported judicial
reform or opposed judicial Kamas just
killed everyone they found and I think
for Israelis we have our passionate
debates in this country just as you have
in Britain and people have democracies
around the world of course we have our
passionate political debate Ates But
ultimately I think October 7th was a
moment when Israelis understood you know
we have enemies and there are people
young soldiers now fighting in Gaza
against Kamas some of them are leftwing
some of them are right-wing they're of
different political opinions but we
understand as a country we have to get
this done Kamas must be destroyed it
must be removed from power we must do
everything that we can to get the
hostages home you always get sent out Mr
regev to defend Israel and you do so
every time and I give you credit for
that uh Benjamin Netanyahu despite
repeated requests from this program to
do another interview I interviewed him
in March um nothing hasn't given a
single interview to a non-american uh
television network is it not time that
he answers some tough questions
himself well he's answering tough
questions every week to the Israeli
media which you know is just as tough as
the British Media or or the American
Media he's been doing these regular
press conferences and asking answering
Jour journalist questions but I'll
ultimately I mean he he's focused today
on winning the war and he's I see him go
in and out of War cabinet meetings and
that this is the big picture because
ultimately it's important that people
understand what Israel is doing and why
we're doing it no I understand that but
he has most important thing is to win
yeah but he's given is to win he's found
time to give interviews to American
Media I think he should give one to
European media I would just like to once
again given that you do come on every
time that we ask you and I give you
credit again for doing that if you could
just pass on that request and I think
you should
I promise to pass on the request sir
thank
you